I think it's bad for women I think it's
bad for both but more so for women
because with men there's a pride
attached to it with women there's a
stigma attached to it so I think
nowadays the women are trying to turn
that stigma into pride and it's not
working that's where the modern women
get lost because that stigma of having a
high body count is no longer there
they're wearing it with pride I think it
also like from a male point of view it
also depends on the people she slept
with to a point as well because if for
example say you live in one of those
areas and a lot of people know each
other okay one of men's biggest I don't
want to say nightmares but hang ups is
bumping into another guy attack oh I
know you'll go like I know her certainly
sorry I think yeah you go actually the
point